I have a suspicion that most of our fans
are hardcore
sports fanatics and
um I think we should talk about baseball
because baseball has changed
significantly this season and
everybody's talking about it I mean this
is a game that has been around it's been
America's past time
forever and going back to the 19th
century and now they've fundamentally
changed it in these fascinating ways
well you've come to the right two people
you guys have any ideas
no clue oh wait you know what I heard
that they did a bunch of stuff to make
the game go faster yes games were
getting very long and I think the
average game at one point was pushing
three hours more than three hours more
than three hours so Eduardo feel free to
time feel free to weigh in because you
know about this but one of the things is
there's a there's a pitch clock so you
know the one you'll be watching baseball
and the pitchers fidgeting and then the
batter steps out of the box but then
gets back in again
and you think this is come on let's go
yeah so baseball players are like
notorious for being habitual everything
so and and superficial uh superstitious
excuse me so they'll reset their batting
glove after every pitch yeah and so
that's what would lead to the three-hour
game but now there's a pitch clock
there's a pitch clock they also made
there's a pitch clock so the pitcher has
to pitch by a certain time the batter
can't be stepping out of the box all the
time right it's like an automatic strike
or ball right if either the pitcher or
the or the batter uh goes over the other
thing they did is they made the bases
bigger how big are we talking like 20
feet it was so funny it's so funny then
I watch Cloud faces they're they're uh
they're much larger I think they're
several inches larger which makes a huge
difference a couple inches bigger yeah
which encourages more stolen bases to
make the game because we're getting into
a rut where it was either massive home
runs or strikeouts this is like what
they did to the Oscars now I'm
understanding what yeah okay okay yeah
and uh but it's got me thinking they
should do more you know like I'm
thinking and this is the thing I've
always thought about which is uh and
just hear me out Baseball fans but
if when you hit the ball
you're up the plate you hit the ball you
have the option you can run to first or
you can run to third that would be
really nice now check this out once
you've committed to your base your base
direction that remains your base
direction for the until yeah you have to
so you have players now you can't just
run to Third and then suddenly be on
Third and just have one more base of
course no no once you run to third third
essentially becomes first but there's a
adds a whole level of strategy and I do
want people to hear me out on this and
consider this this is my platform it's a
brilliant idea and so you have to make
it you have to make a split second
decision about I hit the ball I'm gonna
running to first or am I running to
Third and it changes everything now
here's the cool thing
if you do this you start to get players
Crossing each other in the base path
okay do they have to high five or do
they have to like knowledge no you don't
this is what happens when players cross
each other you use special effects and
one of them it's not dangerous they're
wearing special suits but when they
cross each other both Catch Fire briefly
it would look so cool
no there'd be like a pyrotechnic burst
as they cross each other
and it would look so cool in an
increasingly competitive job market it's
important to make sure your brand stands
out from the crowd that is important
Sona yeah
vegan cupcakes from your kitchen or
marketing your wedding photography
business I'm just making these up yeah I
can tell Squarespace helps you create a
modern platform through engaging and
aesthetically pleasing online presence
that's important if things look nice
people will buy with member areas you
can unlock a new Revenue stream for your
business and free up time in your
schedule by selling access to gated
content like videos online courses or
newsletters newsletters yeah stand out
in any inbox with email from Squarespace
email campaigns collect email
subscribers and convert them into loyal
customers social just play posts from
your social profiles on your website
analytics you want to hear more I'll
give you some use insights to grow your
business learn where your site visits
and sales are coming from and analyze
which channels are most effective good
heavens and alert above head to
squarespace.com Conan for a free trial
when you're ready to launch use offer
code Conan to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain can you
imagine on instant replay like a burst
of flame behind each of their backs
they're fine they're safe but when they
just as they pass each other people
would be watching the game hoping that
players would cross each other on the
base pass so they'd see that burst of
flights like Hunger Games because she
has that dress that goes on fire exactly
and a lot of our sports fans listening
right now really trying to understand
yeah movies right yeah okay all right I
don't know about the fire but okay that
might have been stupid the fire was
Eduardo what do you think I like I like
the idea of being able to run it's great
every direction you want but then what
do you do
when you hit for a double right and you
got to run a second you'll always get it
to Second but then you can get two
people out at the same time without even
doing a double kill like how do double
plays work exactly yeah you just well
you just well step on one base and both
of them are out uh I don't know no no no
that would have to be adjusted and again
that's where I think the Flames might
help
um don't trust me the Flames are I know
it's a little theatrical but uh a little
I'm gonna stick to it okay but um I know
there's stuff that needs to be worked
out I'm not saying that that this is
automatically uh you know okay this is
interesting though because aren't people
like chosen just because they play first
base really well but now they'd have to
be good at first and essentially third
right but also what if then teams would
know the guy at third base isn't as
great so we're gonna quickly uh we're
gonna we're gonna hit the ball and he's
gonna go to third but that may end up
being a mistake depending on where the
other hitters in the lineup hit right so
I think we're basically going is from
Checkers to three-dimensional chess oh I
agree I think this is great is it still
called first second and third base I
mean is it like good question as well
the third should be no no first no no
and then uh first clearly we've chosen
the right committee
yeah second will always be second yeah
yeah
um but if you want if third is thirst
then so be it and uh thirst third and
second what's on thirst yes Third Base
Third Base third base
um
I just think there was a bunch of new
ways to improve the game I agree and is
this helping the time stuff actually the
game's sped up now somebody has to put
out the fire though right so that's
gonna take time no no the fire is not
don't let's not be silly about the fire
oh the fire is not a thing to be
ridiculed or
this isn't funny what it is is it's just
a quick pyrotechnic Burst when they when
they cross each other and um it's just
gonna look very cool no one's what are
they wearing they have stuff on their
head that's Fireproof
by blowing out a birthday candle candle
so it's so easy the amount of stuff in
your hair come on no it's so it's
ridiculous it's so easy for something to
catch on fire you you
practically work candle wax into your
hair every morning
I'm going to talk
thing in here there's just some
mayonnaise and some spackle and that's
it
I'm not going to be ridiculous I just
think a lot of people are gonna die uh I
would make it more first of all that
would get some attention Eduardo that's
what I'm pitching is we keep all the
changes they've made but when you hit
the ball you can choose your own base
path I like it and I would like the
league to start considering my ideas I
think that baseball has taken the first
step but needs to take literally maybe
nine more steps you want to like
professional wrestling
put that veneer on baseball basically I
want the bats to be made of different
materials so the balls move much much
more quickly and are more lethal and um
I think that's going to be cool because
then there's going to be a real like
scary element I got it on that and this
kind of thematically goes with your
basis thing so they don't have a bat
they have a Broad Sword and they can hit
it with the flat end like a bat or they
can hit it with a sharpen and it splits
the ball in two yeah and so then they're
headed towards either Thursday and you
have to field both halves yes yeah in
order for them and by the time they get
home but there's a little gold coin in
the ball yes that comes free when you
cut it in half and if an opposing player
can get to that coin yes and swallow it
yes then everybody's out now we're
talking is it chocolate it's got a
little chocolate in it oh cool yeah but
also for reasons I don't understand some
asbestos as well yes
um ah listen I'm just baseball I'm here
yeah and I am ready to talk because you
just want baseball to contact you yeah
yeah I want the concept of I don't want
to hear from Major League Baseball
boring yeah I want the concept of
baseball can there be like I don't know
robots are there robots in the Japanese
I had a robot waiter come serve me at
Hof's Hut the other day you know that
they could do it at baseball so yeah
well there could be baseball each team
could have one robot okay they're
talking about having robot umpires well
there should be two seasons yeah two
seasons but not you're just you're just
talking about the same kind of robot
that tells you oh I'm thinking no no
you're talking about the kind of robot
that says the ball was uh Over The Line
in tennis which is basically just a
sophisticated laser system we want real
it is my turn to bat suck on this yeah
we want those kind of robots clink Clank
clink Clank yeah did you ever play
baseball I played stickball a lot when I
was a kid okay not coming from like a
position of like you're coming from I
played this and I know it's not even a
little change yeah you didn't play any
little league no I tried to play Little
League when I was in my 30s and they I
was just I didn't play Little League
either you say it like every I thought
every kid played Little League Baseball
we did have a stickball we had a wall
that had a spray painted uh Strike Zone
and I played stickball a lot which I
loved and and we would play it with a
tennis ball okay it was a lot of fun you
were a little rascal I really was and I
I played it and yeah I would sell
newspapers that said the Hindenburg
exploded and then I would go play
stickball with my friends
and then it was time God for all of us
to go up to our tenement house and Ma
would cook us some yam stew then we'd
listen to Roosevelt on the radio
all right that's it for now I'm waiting
for your call baseball